oh
la façon de filmer le foot dans les
petits princes à l'aîné en fait de ma
frustration autant de spectateurs de
justement de ne jamais voir le foot
comme j'avais envie de le voir
la volonté était de rendre le foot le
plus esthétique et le plus élégant
possible
j'ai voulu faire ce que ce qui n'avait
pas été fait en tout cas je pense qu au
cinéma c'était de prendre les comédiens
qui avaient de vraies aptitudes pour
être à côté d'eux de les laisser jouer
et aucun effet spécial il ya aucune
doublure tous les gestes sont réalisés
par les comédiens eux-mêmes concentre
que les mecs on joue au foot et que les
mecs c'est pas des doublures qui font
les gestes et toi tu courais en un film
est comme ça les radiateurs et veut
qu'on joue vraiment ce qui me dit
souvent c'est jouer si tu rates bas on
oublie qu'ils allaient caméra on se
donne vraiment comme si voilà on jouer
entre amis ou dans le quartier il y en a
un qui lâche un pack c'est un vrai
talent si ça pousse ça pousse
sérieusement si ça tombe ça comme
sérieusement les partis pris en fait de
mise en scène est de l'ordre de deux
parties prix essentiel le premier
c'était vraiment d'être une caméra sur
le terrain à côté des des joueurs en
donnant la sensation un peu aux
spectateurs d'être un peu le 12e joueur
de cette équipe
agnel chez fog qui est la caméra épaule
qui te suis partout tu as l'impression
que c'est un joueur qui attend qu'il
fasse la passe ce qui est assez marrant
c'est qu'on doit contourner le la caméra
jouer très proche de la caméra faut
rester dans le champ du steadicam earth
est libre mais c'est quand même une
petite chorégraphie
le deuxième parti pris qui était très
important pour moi c'est de pouvoir a
utilisé le ralenti pour sublimer un beau
geste
j'avais des scènes je mettais des coups
francs ça c'était super dur à faire
puisqu'il fallait être précis fallait
que ça soit beau
là y'a vraiment l'incertitude du ballon
passe quand on entendait un truc très
précis à faire ça pour prendre des
plombes parfois de faire 25 fois la la
frappe vers le but pour des gestes
parfois qui peuvent sembler simple quand
on voit le film enfin pas compte du
temps en fait que ça prend pendant le
tournage